Hello, hi, hello, howdy, how goes it, how it do, what will happen in here, what's happening
in the background, um, there's a thingy and it, is this how big it is or is that like,
oh that's me, what is happening in the background, I, there's an echo, there's an echo, there's
an echo, oh, there it is, I figured it, I'm gonna grab my tissues, okay.
You
you
is he short, why is this man so small, Borderlands 2, into the Borderlands, Borderlands, Electric
Blue, hold on, my game is like, not properly centered, why is it like that, well, okay,
we're just gonna, it's gonna be slightly cut off, because I don't know why the, whatever,
why is my, I refresh this chat like 50 times and it's still not working, he's a dwarf, oh
my gosh, does she be high, these are all eight, these are, everyone else is really tall, Salvador's
5'8", what the hell, why is everybody so freaking tall, that doesn't make any sense, why do I have to do terms of
serve, you know what, forget the, sorry guys, you don't get a chat, no chat for you, destroy it, chat is the
mind killer, cool, my playing, zero, naturally, because that looks cool as hell, I don't know, can I choose, I don't
know how this works, I've never played, I've never played at Borderlands, I've had this game, I've had
Borderlands 1 and 2 sitting in my steam, for like, I don't even know how many years, yeah, we're doing the second
game because people said it was better, let's do, let's do window capture, chat, window, hey look it's you guys, nope, we're
doing this buddy, yeah, look it, there's two, look it it's you, I'm, you know what, I'm going to change from the cat girl
because I literally just didn't have time, okay, oop, I didn't mean to do that, hello you, say hi to yourselves, nope, hey look it's
me and all my tabs, I should just have you guys in the center of my screen like that, I'm going to have to start doing this
for now, I can't even change the resolution, not the resolution, the box size, sorry, you guys are going to be over here, cut off the heart,
high clip or is somebody going to clip, I'm going to cut off the whole top part, I don't hope it's nothing important there, don't put baby in the
corner, speaking of babies, I'm so pissed I miss my friends, because she's my best friend and I missed her child's birthday, because I was sick and it was cute because it was, it was like warped tour themed
because they're a bunch of men and kids, or alternative kids, I don't know, I also have my food with me, yeah it was, see what the plan was was I was going to stream and then after I streamed I was going to leave
because she lives over an hour away from me, yeah but still, it still bothers me, I just made sweet potato fries and chicken tenders, yeah the next time I see her I'm going to bring the present with me
um, last time I got baby a squishmallow, so this time I'll get her something cooler, yeah I'm just really, because they also haven't hung out with those people in a long time, so I just bummed, I was bummed, but they, she didn't mind at all, they were like oh if you're sick of course, like it's fine, it's just me, I just beat myself up over it, um, is this sound okay, is it too loud, get her a puppy,
she already has two cats, so I don't think her mom would like that, and I think they're allergic, I think, I think the dad is allergic to God, so I don't know, get her a very noisy toy, don't sick the child, yeah I also don't want to, she gets sick really easily the baby, so, I have a picture of her, I'm also, you know what else, I'm essentially like her godmother so like that's another thing,
Another thing that's why I'm just like I miss my godchild's birthday
Kind of quiet well, I think I'll leave it for now and we'll see
But yeah, I have to I have to bring the present to Goddard
I should get her a tomagotchi no kidding. I don't think I don't think she can use some I just give her my
Tom, and I'm kidding. Wait, let's check on my tomagotchi everybody
It's dead
Hi
Hi, Pimpals. We're just about to start. I was just telling everybody how my
newest tomagotchi is dead because I killed it because it was ugly um
Borderlands for wishlist now. Oh, no, thank you
No, no, it's fine. It's ugly. It's okay
Throw another just throw the body onto the pile. I don't even know what it turned into it just died
All right guys pick an egg color
Hi hi, Pimpals. I hope you had a good time within me
Hope you guys played the what was it? What was it? You guys are doing something iPhone related iPhone video games iPhone mobile game
I don't remember
But I bet I bet it was silly because Amy always has silly streams
Blue blue we did purple last time. We'll do blue
The iPhone games. Oh my god. Did she play?
They played torque. He said did you guys I think somebody was telling me so I ended up looking it up. Did you guys play?
um
What's it called?
sorry the
Throwing off by vealer and joyer in my chat because I just love some of you guys make alt accounts just to talk to us
It's very easy to me. Um
Did you guys play like the steam games that are like that are the real versions of the games? Did you guys do that?
Maybe me if there's multiplayer, maybe I'll you played bit life. I've actually played bit life before
I
I've actually paid bit life. That's cool. Yeah, and me. Let's I'll see if I can find the games
I it's like I it's something like iPhone games, but they're blah blah blah blah. It was 99%
That's why I have Apple Arcade, baby
We didn't play bit life. Oh, I liked bit life. I played it a little bit
We're almost the one at first came out. I have no idea when that came out
I just remember it was like years ago
And we got 38% pregnant and then he gave up because there's too many ads
Yeah, like I remember when I played there was gonna be like a few ads, but this is a long time ago. So
That's so funny
Honestly, some of the game like I'm so mad because some of those games look so fun
And then you're like, oh
Like I was watching one where you have to like save a king
and like
Get them out from from being crushed by rocks or like gold and I'm like, oh
But it's fake. It's all fake. It's all a sigh up. They all just want to take your
information and sell it
to countries
They're all clickbait
They also call it what
And what did you call her? Huh?
Which form
This is why I saw me the game that yeah, yeah, yeah, that's what I'm talking about
Literally, oh you called
That's so funny. He just really called her ace like
What the hell was that
That was weird, um
Yeah, you want those games right? So here you go. No, let's yes. Yes. I think that was it. I don't know
That was the game that's clap trap. Oh again, I've never I know who clap trap is what I've never played this
It was through it just threw me off because I'm like there it's spinning in the background
I need a shift display name. That's perfect name is already taken
I don't want to play multiplayer
My first gun. Wow. Fabulous. This is making me dizzy. I hate when they do this. Stop spitting. Just just hang out, please
It makes me so fucking nauseous
um
She slammed dunked a baby. That's pretty cool
Well, I'm gonna eat some of my chicken tendies because I have two left
I have some ranch and I have some honey mustard
I like honey mustard and then I dip it in the ranch or vice versa. I used to hate ranch
What makes you think I have the dlc characters?
What makes you think I have any of that stuff?
When I've never played this game
Because you probably bought this well, actually, yeah, maybe I did
Because I bought I bought it with the first game
And the um, it was bundled with the first game in the game of the year for the first game edition
I dropped 20 mustard on my shirt
I have everything
Is this all stuff that I have
Is this stuff that I own
I don't know
Yeah, what the hell how do I have all of this?
Oh
What
Oh, okay, you guys can't see that. I just got really scared that I just like because my whole steam just threw up
Um, well, I don't really care about dlc stuff right now. I'll be honest with you
I never played borderlands. Hold on. You know what? Let's do something. What's that say?
Why isn't this showing up? Oh, it's because it's below the
I have never played any borderlands stop asking
Okay
They'll put that right up there. So I don't have to keep repeating myself
Lovely, uh, I'm also going to take off my ears. Let's just let's just hi
Hi, I thought this outfit would be fine
Since I have like a bat and I feel like it fits the colors of borderlands. So I was like, yeah, let's do it. Um
But how many borderlands have you played what?
People are still
Should I put it on my titties like will you guys be able to see?
Well, if I have any mods here if anybody asks you can just time them out
I guess let's do whatever. Um
Hold on uno momento. Let me just eat
Eat
Sorry
All right
It me, you know what?
Is there
Yeah, they come off. They're my these ears are a part of me the other ears were not
You think I'm joking
You think I'm joking, uh, hold on. I also need to change my my neck skin tone because it doesn't match
I don't know if it's I'm sick or if it's allergies, but I'm sick. Ooh, you can see my v-line in this model
Who are we playing as I don't freaking know? I just got here
Help what am I doing? Where's my neck?
I just oh I can have a white neck
There we go, that's a little bit
That's better
Whoa
You didn't see anything
Um
Guys stop trolling
Madam doesn't like it
You're making her angry. We can pretend. This is my tail. I have let I have a bunny tail. Hold on
We can pretend this is my bunny tail
Okay, so when I turn to the side
That looks realistic, right? That that's pretty good. Why hello? Can I please rotate it?
Perfect
I need to plug it in
Whoa, all right, I'm locked in boys
Super realistic, you know what I wanted to do like I was honestly, um
Hold on. Let me throw this away real quick. You know what I was wondering if I ever get a
Like a cute and funny model
I'm debating whether or not to give myself a massive bunny tail. Like if you know like a giant cotton tail
And then then I would actually be cotton bomb. So I'm tempted to do something like this. Let me show you
Um, because like you don't see a freaking tail
And honestly, I've also been forever did it wrong. I've also been a little bit inspired
by me was designed
Because she has like little like puffs around her and I was like, oh, maybe
I can use some puffs. Uh, I was also thinking about just reusing and re-skinning my rena model that I got from swalcoy
I'll I can show it to you guys. I don't really care
I showed her on a member stream like a very long time ago, but I can show you guys, uh, let me do
And just re-skinning it because I again, I spent like three thousand dollars on a model
I never used so I would like to use it at some point
Where is it? Oh, there it is. So if I did like
Like something like that
Oh, that's my body. Sorry
Let me make this bigger
Like you can see that it's like I have a giant fucking tail
But just imagine me cute and funny with the giant fucking tail
You know
Yeah, here I'll I'll show it to you guys I never show I only showed the members not even my
I never showed it to
Uh, anybody besides the members
I know it is hard to see but if I was
Never mind, um
Dullahan problems for real. Maybe my 2.0. I should just full-on become a Dullahan
But I'll show you I had a casual outfit for Rina. I never got to use
Let me see if I can find it. Thank you
Here it is
So this was my Rina outfit
You can see the surprise guys. Hi. I'm gonna know. Um
But imagine if I just did bunny ears made myself blonde made everything red
Um
Yeah
And like I was and I was I was a Siamese cat
So I know I want to be a Himalayan bunny
Uh, so I was
I was tempted
Yeah, it was a really freaking cute design and I never got to use it
And I spent a lot of money
So I want to reuse this and I know swalkoi totally would swalkoi is a real one
There if you're if you're a vtuber watching this and you want a really quality model and someone that's just like generally a wonderful person to work with
Uh, they will they will do that
Uh, yeah the poof around like honestly like I literally look like I'm related to miwa like it's so adorable
I bet she would love this if she saw it. I never showed it to her. Um, but yeah
So I might rework that at some point
Yeah, so that's a little spoiler
If I decide to reskin it, uh, we'll see we'll see we'll see
Yeah, the poof around the wrist was really bunny like I agree
Um
Tim gun make it work. Hold on. Let me just I can't just my freaking phone
Oh, yeah, I know everybody would die of heart attacks. You'll be very funny. I'm already full
I've only had a couple bites
Um, or again, I might just get the art that I got commissioned
So we'll see
Because you guys have seen the delinquent sheebie art
Again, I could totally rework that
because
It has um, it has a nude base because um, I had multiple outfits for it. It was that was that outfit and another outfit
Boomi actually didn't come over to check it out. I don't know. Oh, he's sleeping
Okay, I'm out of water good thing I have
My lemonade that I brought out just in case
This is lemonade from a while ago that I ordered
For my ice from my cup and that
I think I should add fit. Yeah, I would so I would add like the harness and stuff
Um
And all that that jazz
Was boomi making noise because I was looking at like there was a comment under the space that said what that like boomi
Boomi that boomi was doing something. Is it the lemonade they give me tummy issues? Yes
Okay, it turned into tusk touchy and it was naughty and it died that was the name of the tomagotchi
By the way, tusk touchy. That is the weirdest name for tomagotchi
Boomi was scratching
Oh, if that that was rena
That was rena that was rena, uh, probably scratching litter box. Was it like this? Hold on
Was it like that?
Uh
The acid hurt my tummy
Sometimes then I have too much acid
Not that loud. Well, yeah, because I wasn't right and I like I'm at my desk now. But like I was at mom my couch before
um
But that that's that's rena
I fell asleep. I woke up a cheapy stream. Hi. Hi. Um
Reina just
Doesn't have the concept that she's supposed to
Scratch the litter and not the actual box and bear to like use the bathroom
But um, yeah
Okay, so we have a baby now. I've select I've selected the blue egg
The blue egg will be rolling around
He made great wookie sounds
Was that fia or b because I heard myself snoring I was going
Like I was I started something in the chat say I was doing hunk
hunk sheebie hunk sheebie sheebie boo or whatever hunk shoe instead of hunk shoe. I was like hunk
Uh hunk me me me it was like hunk sheebie boo, but then there was there was a different snore
That was fia because you were guys so I placed you on top of fia's bed
Like you know how it's like a little like ring
And she's in the center. I put you on the outside of the ring. So it was her then you then me
and so hunk sheebie me me me
So the little the little like like hum noises, uh, that was fia fia snores
Uh boomy doesn't snore reina reina snore sometimes
But yeah, I snore I also snored because I had my mouth open because I can't breathe
But I'm happy you guys liked the fact that my farting
My farting uh
Snores were uh attractive to you
They did sound cute
um
It wasn't as like crazy as it could be because I know sometimes my
They can be super crazy
But it was funny
I was listening back and I like literally like snore and it sounds and then I sound like I'm fucking choking
It was so funny
You know those one hour silencer to both fia at random times
Oh really? Okay, maybe I'll make it into an ASMR
I'll maybe I'll like send it to straw and you'll be like, can you do anything with this?
Can you download the sound?
Was it great sleeping?
Yeah, I just I was just again
I just wanted to hang out with you guys and just like pretend like we were in bed
Just like with the cat with fia and just like chatting
Except we're just listening to me yap and mumble as I fall asleep
Was this all early in the stream? No, it was a twitter space. I felt it's on my alt account. I um
I was like nap with your sick gf and so I just fell asleep on in the um
In the twitter space for a couple hours and so I was just snoring
And uh
Yeah, I don't know why I'm looking at myself right now and I have never felt
More like myself than now. It is so weird. I just had this weird
Like I'm looking I'm like and I'm looking at my model and I'm like that looks like me
And it was really weird
I mean, maybe it's the outfit because it's something that I would totally wear
Um, that was really funny that was that is like really clicked for me that I really like this outfit
Because this is 100 something that I'd wear
um
and
Yeah
Is it the sweet potato fries?
Uh, hold on my friend with the baby's texting me
Oh, yeah, she's like, oh, I hope you feel better
And freckles they're super cute. Yeah, because I have freckles too
Um, I really like this outfit
It's just like it just really it just felt feels really me if I just had like a couple of moles on my body
It'd feel even better. That's so funny. It just fucking locked and I also have a barrette
I could beat you with if a baby texted me. I would simply not answer
Um, it'd be funny if the baby could text me. Uh, she is too young to do so
um
But yeah, this out like I don't know why that just like felt really
Really, right? Um
Now I can sing
Like I haven't started the game yet and it's already been 30 minutes
I can be like
Peanut butter jelly with the baseball bat
Wee-yah, wee-yah, wee-yah, wee-yah
The disto, disto, disto, disto
Peanut butter jelly, peanut butter jelly
Oh
Wait, I can actually more accurately show you guys my moles. Oh, there's one right here. So I'll go on right here
Boop
And then I have some more on my face. I want on my nose, but that just looks weird when I try to put it on
The most noticeable one if I have a mole like right on my nose not like a mole
It's like it's a fucking beauty mark and it's funny because my dad has one in the same exact spot
You can't really see it of course because he's like super fucking dark skinned, but it's funny
He has the same exact moles, um, beauty mark in the same exact spot
um
And let me do another one
I need to put a toggle to put in crustables the fact I actually don't have an uncrustables png is ridiculous
All right
And then well
I have one on my armpit, but I can't put it there. Wait, let me look at my arm
Because I have one on my arm
Yes, it's right there
So I have one right here
It's not gonna stay, but it's fine
Uh
So, uh
Canonically I have one right here
But I or all I actually have one right here
So I'll put it right there
And it's not gonna stay but it's fine. We're just we're just getting a general idea
And then
I have
Well, I could it looks like weird if I put two there, so I'll just do one on my shoulder
I
Have one in the center of my chest as well. Um, I have one like
Right, where is it? Hold on you look at my stomach. I can't see this look dark in my room
I have it
Where are you?
It's to the side
There it is
Cut around which side it was on it's on this side. It's a little bit smaller than the others
Beauty mark show and tell
And then I have so I have one like right above my
Uh
Bean
And then I have one on one lip and I have one on the one look down there, but other than I have one right here
And then
And then they have
One on the other side, but it's a little bit smaller and a little bit lower. It's like that
And then I have like a couple of like like a couple wait, hold on. What's the where's the one on my hip?
Is it on this hip or the other hip?
It's a little I can't my ass too fat
And then I can't show my one on my feet because I have one on my foot
It's really right in it
Where's the one on my foot? It's literally right under
My index toe on my
Under my index toe on my left foot
Oh
Thank you, thank you
I put my headphones back in out sometimes I sneeze too hard and it hurts my neck and then it hurts my shoulder
Because I have neck and spine issues
Um
Do I I know I have more on my legs, but it was too lazy. I also have one really up high
It's like right
Here
it's like
Literally like right there
But yeah, I have a lot
I'll stick it there for now. That's actually pretty accurate. Well, uh
It looked like I just got a lot of bugs on me
I like to collect them all connect them all like a constellation. Yeah, I get cramps in my arms
It's like my ribs and spine took a screenshot for real
All right, we were playing a game right
Oh
What the fuck was that
Was that clap trap again? Where is he like falling down the river?
Is he like falling off of it
Oh, there he is
I found him it's like playing eye spy or where's clap trap
So
You want to hear another story, huh? Yeah one where the very fate of pandora hangs in the balance pandora
Not too bad. I'm telling you anyway. Am I playing avatar?
An alien prison
Cool to the warriors
The vault was just a container of tentacles and disappointment
They vanished into the wastelands
Sure that the vault held no treasure at all
They were wrong
The vault's opening triggered the growth of iridium a priceless alien element
Okay, soon the rare invaluable mineral emerged all across pandora. Okay
It's attracted many including the hyperion corporation
What is hyperion came to pandora to mine iridium and bring order to the savage
This is like through their excavations hyperion uncovered evidence of an even greater
Vibranium
Kidding to use its power to civilize the borderlands once and for all
What's the lore the only one searching for the next vault's alien power?
What's the lore the call of danger and loot is not so easily like what what time period is this like how far into the future
I know the video is the lore but like
I want to play gen g
He doesn't really look that handsome to me in my opinion
Super future. I know it's sci-fi
But I like a time period like it's 33,000 bazillion years in the future
Okay, I haven't watched this part yet. I added with the headphones and at least
I can skip it right no, I can't um
It's another planet she be there is no, okay. I'm just asking
Damn bitches god damn
Space wild west
Oh, no poor guy. That's not nice
Was this loosely based off of mad max, okay, what the fuck he looks like he's four feet tall
Oh
Crap
The more you know
You
You're lying if he's five eight is everybody looks seven fucking feet tall
What is this a joker this is Arkham city
Is this sucker punch, I'm kidding
So I'm assuming these are the DLC characters what the hell I can't even I just want to click on people
Sorry I'm eating my chicken tendy my last chicken tendy
Macro man sir
This is literally just emmy
Krieg psycho I don't why does it keep opening steam? I just want to see what they look like bro. What the hell
Oh
Witness me Salvador
Maya
Decepticon oh deception. I thought it said he was a decepticon
Brother
Salvador is easiest. Well, I don't who's the hardest
You play a gauge because tiny girl and robot
How do I want to play I want to honestly I want to be this dude
So I want to be I want to be Genji. I want to be
I want to be Rex Wexler
What is that I want to be the Rizzler
What's his name from Tron be who you want to be Barbie girl
Is
Everybody else fucking dead
Claptrap you are not getting anywhere
Is that the same voice actor for from Invader Zim
Or they would if any of them sounds like
I only speak in haikus, so I'm Genji
Sick
Yeah, it sounds like gr. I almost said grew
Are you telling me this bro? I thought this was one of the dudes
Oh my god, my sensitivity is so high
Are you telling me I can't okay, I was gonna say oh, let me turn my sensitivity down
Let's do it to 40 and see if that helps
I
Still so fucking high
Shut up. He just yaps doesn't he he's a yaptrap. He's like me for real for real
Turn it to fucking zero
What I liked about my
My logitech
G 303, I think what it was
Um the one that shroud uses
I used it before him just saying uh is that I could click
The center of my mouse like right before this under the scroll wheel and I had three presets for mouse sensitivity
And it would do it automatically for me regardless of the game and I love that so much and yeah
Yeah
But logitech is such like odd double click, but yeah reason
Oh, does this one not have it? No, I'm using my razor. Um death adder chroma
Bro, did you get any sleep? It doesn't sound like it. Also bless you. Thanks. Jesus fucking christ. I'm sick
Yes, I slept for literally three hours with harem
um
But
Yeah, I like I like that because um
It was good for fps games
Why do you look hyper realistic
Your mouth isn't moving. Hey
You're so cute to be honest
Your old razor mouse has the buttons. Yeah, I've had this this death adder chroma for a really long time
I use it as a backup mouse because my logitech was double clicking, but that's because I spilled something on it
Actually, no
You are a sassy one you're just like me. Oh my god sarcastic sarcastic
Um, no, that was my one previous to this. Um to my other one
No, this one I bought
The other ge 303 I bought off ebay and I asked them
Does it double click and they said no it doesn't
And it did so it was a waste of of like 70 bucks
So I had this one, but this one's like a couple like quite a few years old
So that's I'm I know it's just due to age so it's double clicking this razor mouse. So that's why I put another one on my throne
Oh my god, I love you so much. That's literally me
Why are there just feet standing in there
for emergencies, but in here we should be pretty safe
I'm dead
Oh no claptrap
No, why did he just take his eye?
Oh claptrap
The gun is a cabinet. Where's the cabinet? There's a dead dude here. Um
It's not the cabinet. Oh there it is
He got a gun he moved five feet and opened a locker. I like how meta this game is uh
I will I'm already looking back
Once upon a time four bolt hunters changed pandora forever, but their time has passed
Thanks to handsome jack
Pandora needs a new hero. Can I take this money?
Apart from these crocheting pain. This is crazy these cards
Yeah, cool, uh, hold on. I'm gonna try to loot some bodies
I
Oh my god, what is that
You got anything on you you guys know, I just love looting bodies
and touch and haughties what's over here
Those claptraps
Fascinating
All right, my claptrap wants me to go the other way
I literally pressed control like I was gonna fucking slide like it was um
Titanfall
You're some medicine money. Thank you. I took medicine. I don't
He put it said I can't take a certain amount within a certain amount of hours
And I don't want to overdose on like allergy pills or cold medicine
What is this?
I don't know what I'm picking up
Is this stealing I don't he's not saying anything about it. So maybe because you can't see me
You bet sis
Rockers can be looted
I'm gonna run into anything but thank you James for the super
It's like I was fine when I woke up and now I'm dying again
No, now I have so much fucking ammo. Wait, wait, what's that? Oh
Fascinating
Is my health regenerating or I wasn't looking my way around this glacier
I bet you will find my eye and frostbite crevasse frostbite crevasse smash. Oh, sorry
That's a lot of why is there so much ammo he will help you get off this glacier and into the city of sanctuary
Thank you
Whatever lady, what is that? I don't what did I just pick up was that health or a fucking flare
Let's go this way
I'll use a lot of ammo. I have to heal myself
Protect me squire
The mission has an area way point area way points give you the general location of your objective
You must search the area to find it. Oh
No, I need to be told exactly where something is
Surringes our health, okay
You just make me sick
You make me so sick
You're so disgusting
The smell of you is absolutely revolting
Um
Okay, I have to fart but I can't mute
Why does it have money? Okay, I farted silently nobody could hear it
Okay
Party like I can't get over how cute and dupy this thing is
Oh bones why not I just pick you up like just let me carry you dude
Hey
Bazinga
Really awesome voice acting
Yeah, you already said that lady
Okay
These are jumping over
Yeah
It's very short burst
I'm missing
I'm not really a good shot
How oh you're bigger how
You do use a lot of ammo I'm happy I picked all that shit up instead of just following him
How do I how do I heal is it tab I feel like it's tab
It's automatic I auto heal on pickup understood that's cool
Shut up
I am that's exactly what I'm thinking
You would be totally right about but as a stand right now
Oh cat food dispenser my beloved
The voice acting is so good, where did he go?
Friend of friends
Do vaults like spawn with the other day like mines of the airy rerun
How does he have my like ability to talk to me? How's him? How'd he got my number?
Oh
Okay, hold on. I have to go feed the baby
Jack knows all handsome jack
He's not by handsome to me all right
Salma salma salma salma salma sounds like Spanish to me
Jack hired me understood you found my number in a phone book
I
Everyone has my number
Okay time to feed fia you guys can hear her munch
Little girl
I
Right now keep eating right I guess easily distracted when he takes the opportunity to take her food
Got that let me get you a lot of
I accidentally spilled some I think I knocked it when I was sleeping
Because it was by my feet and I kicked it
Yeah, but I feel what's fall on the ground
Still need to brush her she's a little
I gave her a bath, but I kind of just I didn't want to stress her out anymore by giving her a brush
I
Hi, do you want to come with me? Yeah
You smell delicious you smell absolutely delectable
Yeah
Are you gonna squeak?
Oh little girl
I
Fia crunch time
Here Fia. Let me tuck you up
Yeah
See you're popping a squat hanging out with me
Fia did she was snoring she was over a great time here you go
A little big crunch
Sorry, I distracted you with the microphone ignore it just eat
My nose is itchy. Anyways, I gotta get some meat out of my some cat crunches
Fia keep the food in your mouth
She's like looking over to the side and accidentally throwing it on the floor. Thankfully boomie will just eat it
Crunch crunch crunch
I
Don't know if you guys remember that like video of that cat that's like
Sticks its head into a giant thing of kibble
It just like has its mouth like unhinged and like tries to grab it all. That's literally Fia right now
Oh
Hi, if you're new here, my name is Shibi and my cat Fia she's disabled. So I have to um
Well, she's like
she's
She's a weird autoimmune disease where she gets paralyzed temporarily
Um, because her mind can't communicate to her body to move. So I have to like
Feed her myself
But she's doing a lot better. She takes medication for it. So she just had a little bit of a flare up
Um, she could kind of move the front half of her body right now
And I hope that her back legs follow suit. This is the longest it's taken for her to um
To recover from it
My cat eats sideways
She's getting better each day. Yeah, she's doing she's doing good
I give her her meds three times a day
um
She also gets a steroid to help with that
She is a good cat. She's a very good girl
Although it was really funny
I was laughing at her because and I really shouldn't have because I know she was just scared
so
Fia doesn't have like the best like grip strength with her like mouth like she can't really like bite
But like I was when I was giving her a bath because she had made a little bit of a mess of herself last time
She's the bathroom
um
She was just going ah like she was like
Like because she was so mad that I was like giving her a bath
And then when I was I picked her up to dry her off. She tried to like bite my hand, but it looked like
Do you know that?
Do you know that tick talk of that girl like holding up that cat and it kind of just like
Just like wiggles a lot and tries to bite her in her arms. She's just sitting standing sitting there
Just like are you done? And it's just like it's this black and white cat. I think
It's really fun because she's trying to do that, but she can't move
So she's like trying to move to bite me and I'm like ma'am
I know you're mad right now, but you smelled
And I have to wash you and I know you just want me to release you but you need a bath here you go
And it was like a very like it was it wasn't like a bite bite. It was just like let me go
Are you already done eating here and you want some water do you want to wash it down with some wawa?
Or you want to wash it down some ranch because they have some ranch next to me as well for you if you would like some ranch
Here you go
I
Don't walk over an inch
Yes, I call water wawa
Chug chug chug chug she's doing a keg stand right now you guys can't see
Hey done here looks like you're thinking about it. Okay. He makes like little sucking noises. It's funny
Damn girl you thirsty
I literally tried to give her water when I woke up if she wasn't interested now
She's suddenly interested in water
Yes, the appetite and like the interest in food is a great sign
Boomi boomi, please boomi stop eating her food boomi. I will blow on you
He doesn't like to be blown on I discovered this recently he doesn't like to have his face face blown on
That's the only because of my hands are full. I'm holding fia and the water so I can't like move him
So I have to blow on him
Fia you look so funny
Also, yeah fia has a really goofy looking face because her face when her face also gets paralyzed and uh, it's like someone someone has a stroke
So like half of her face is paralyzed right now. So she's like one big eye and one small eye and she's like extra cross-eyed
But I love her. I love her little goofiness. You have food on your belly here. Let me get that for you
You want to eat it?
Are you gonna eat for my hand?
You haven't eaten a lot
Do you not like this flavor?
You've you've eaten this before it's brown chicken and rice lady
Here munch
Well, you did actually have a pretty big lunch. She like when I um
Before I fell asleep I fed her and she ate a lot
Are you done?
Do you need to use the bathroom?
Actually, you know what? I'll put you right next to me because I have the bed
And if you wiggle a lot or meow, I'll know you have to use the bathroom
You're gonna hear her squeak when I move her. Don't worry. She's not in pain
She's just letting me know that she doesn't like she's just doesn't like being picked up. Well, not she likes being picked up, but
How bad didn't you have no use of your body and someone just is moving you around constantly you're gonna go?
Are you mad at me
Can I have a kiss
You're not giving me a kiss. Okay, but you're giving let me give you a trim scratchies
Okay, and he gave me a little purr
All right, I'll put you down right here boom comfy lady if you have to use the bathroom, give me a hauler
You look quite cute
Hi
Oh
My eye it's just
She's
She's just burying herself in the bed
Kiss denied
I know she didn't give me a kiss. Can you believe this?
She loves to give kisses
She doesn't want to give me a kiss
So I think she's still mad at me for giving her a bath girl. Are you trying to suffocate yourself?
She shoved her head inside of her bed and again, I'm like it looks like she's trying to
Stop trying to commit sweet say doll
I'm kidding. She's fine. Um, let me blow my nose
Because I napped for so long I might stream this for a bit
And because I my my sleep schedule is gonna be messed up
I need to put my chair for her
Okay, now I'm sitting up
Hi, oh you're licking your paw paws
Oh, I couldn't fall asleep for a little bit because like she was just licking the bed. I don't know if you guys are going
He's like constantly licking her bed
I'm like, why are you licking your bed? Like there's nothing
Boomi go away
You cannot have this
It is not your food. It is Fia's food
I'm hiding it
Are you trying to steal a french fry?
Well, you can have a french fry. That's actually fine
Here, do you want a french fry? Have a french fry mister. Stop trying to lick the ranch. I don't think you can eat ranch
Here you want this?
Go on
He licks it so gingerly. He's like
Like so soft
Here take the french fry
There you go. No, you dropped it. Go grab it. Take it with you
Take it to go
Go on
Take take your french fry to go here. I'll throw it on the floor for you because you don't like eating a pie. Go get it
There's no tenders to be had I can't give him a tender if there's none
Boomi would probably just throw it up because he'd eat it so fast
Oh
Fia, do you want french fry?
Here you go. Fia, would you like a fry?
Oh no
Oh, I like sneezed and now I have like a burp hiccup suck in my throat thing
She's eating her fry. Boomi you can't come back for another fry. You got a fry
You only get one. You know the rules
Yeah
One of my cats will know. Yeah, boomi likes vegetables. He likes to eat bean sprouts. He likes cabbage
Um, he he also likes arugula as well, which is very funny to me
Uh
Excuse me. That was for my sneeze and the burp that I was telling you about
I was stuck in my chest
Is there any food? I don't know. Boomi doesn't like um anything minty
He hates the smell of mint
Him and Fia hate the smell of mint because it's very strong to them
Is
Eating as much grass that would be boomi. He would just eat grass
Uh, boomi ate a beetle the other day and it was really grossed out
Uh, he ate a fly the other day and because like a fly got in after I opened the balcony door
And I'm like, can you not like get worms from some random fly eat?
Oh
Why is it wearing that
Why did it appear where it threw the car
It's very hard to dogs
Oh, what is it what the fuck is the gravity of this place?
This gun sucks
Is it stuck?
I think it's stuck
Well, that works out for me
The fuck
That's fine
Where's this money
Can I just run over it? Okay, I can't oh fuck
You didn't see you there bud. I killed your little leader and you're gonna I'm out of ammo
Curses empty
Can I have ammo please?
Ow
Huh
I literally have only fucking eight bullets, bro
Ow stop
Okay, at least I had
Wall sphincters I okay, you know speaker truth queen
Do you need me to grab your eye?
Oh my god because it glitched can I not retrieve its eye?
Oh my god, it's not over myself
Yes, I know I see it right here. You don't have to tell me
I gotta find someone to put it back into me. Okay
Did you just speak friends?
Oh my god
Hello
Ha
Nice fucking going claptrap you don't have anything sassy to say
How the fuck can you do that?
Oh
I just don't like that you're a human just overlaid with a weird filter. You're not a video game character
Why does the AI have to look like a real person? Can I please take?
Over here. Let me know when you're
Okay, thank you. I understand
I tell me I can't get more than this. Come on. Just let me pick up the extra shit
You know, I've actually forgot I had the ammo for that
People just leaving money around, huh
Is there a pick up all button there probably is
Yes, little boy. Hold on. I'm mommy's busy. Mommy's busy being a ninja
Can I pick up the money let's go this way in a moment
Uh
Cleaning up the Berg hold e gotcha
I need to sneeze again
The green dots are the yellow paint of the game. Well, this is a red dot
Why the fuck do you just throw yourself off cliff, booby, please stop
Oh my god
I
Packed up into a fucking wall
I'm sneezing leave me alone
Booby stop licking the ranch
Ah
Can cats have ranch can somebody look that up for me? He's just literally just licked all the fucking ranch
I wasn't looking and I was sneezing
I
Small amount of ranch, okay
Okay, that's fine. I just don't want him to accidentally
He gets sick sick. He's probably gonna throw it up later
Oh
Wait, what do I have to kill people what the fuck I just got here
I was not paying attention because my cat was eating ranch. Please for the love of god
Is there a better gun let me try this one. This is the same fucking gun just re-skinned
Just kill that slag leg
He's calling me a slag
You're fucking slug
Oh
Are you serious? I just can't do that right now
Can can they just like third party the bully monks for me because I don't feel like it
Oh, yeah, you know what you're trying to kill him. So
I am seven health
I am 11
Oh, thank god for fall damage. No fall damage
Hold on
I will be there momentarily
Uh, please hold
Hopefully you're all just fighting each other. Do I have like I thought I was a sniper. Where the fuck is my sniper gun?
I'm out of ammo. Oh
I literally just want to I'm accidentally just pressing control to slide
Okay
Yep
Can I have zeds man's
Actually, no, I think I'm fine
All right
Ready bully mong needs correction after I got one, okay
I just want to slide
Honestly understandable
Hunter scholar gentlemen
No problem kiddo
Myself
No problem
I like how they have like smash bros intros
So literally all had to do is push it in
Hold on my tamagotchi is already fucking dying
I'm wearing a mask how could you even fucking tell?
The baby's chat everywhere
How are you doing see uh speaking of babies? Oh, he didn't eat your fry. She's like was looking at
Mari is the robot fuck. I actually put a tissue in the water
Time Mari
Unfortunately, she'd be circumlocked as a man's man. Am I not a man's man? Am I not a um a woman's bro?
Am I not a bros bro?
you know
Well, I like the I like the robot Mari and it's me and Mari identify with this robot
I have a lot of money. I wish I had this much money in my bank account
Um
Guns holy shit, can I hack stuff? Is there hacks in this game?
Shooty pistol little pistol
Is there a pic is there a pic pic walking walking picking
Wait, where am I? Excuse me. Where am I going? Where is it on the minimap?
Is
East okay, because I was not paying attention to what they were saying north
Never eat soggy waffles. Okay. Uh wait, then it would be that way
Guys what the fuck
Is
Over here, okay, just hey, what's up, brother?
Oh my god
Never eat shreddy wheat shredded wheat never eat sour watermelon
You didn't watch borderlands rain it. What is that? No, I didn't watch anything
Okay
Do I speak to you? All right
I'm dying
Guys I think you need to put me out of my misery it did hurt actually like made me strain my neck
Oh kitty shield
I now have a shield damage inflicted potty will be the first removed from the shield
Okay
Handsome jack tipped four dollars and 20 cents. Thank you handsome jack
Handsome jack again if you could do me a favor and jump off a cliff it would save me some money
Okay, you see paying your bounty would amount to a zero point. Oh
One decrease. Oh, that's just bad for business. Oh like you roaming around
Oh
Thank you handsome jack for donating to tell me to jump off of a cliff
It's always funny to me when you guys role playing in the the tts. It's like it's actually really funny and enjoyable for me
Um tts started gooning for a second
Nope that guy got got he got fucking shot mod stand down. It's fine
I do have one question about your tommy hort earlier. It's not pleasant
But god's else for me. I took a shot of warm blooming juice every few hours and made
I couldn't do that because the acid
No, it's not marie marie can't do anything marie only marie has what's called the hot girl wrench
Yeah, I don't know why like
Maybe I should take like a fucking a fucking pseudofed. That'll knock me out though. Like I'm I know if I take something
I'm gonna fall asleep
Like I should get the hot girl wrench it's a hot girl wrench summer
um
You know what I realize it looks like I'm not wearing clothes when I lean forward
Why are you crying tomagotchi? It's like saying my name all sad. What is boomi doing?
Everybody all the cats are staring at him like he's acting weird
Okay, wait, why do I have mail guys I have mail for my tomagotchi
Tom our hurdles open. Oh, there's another is a new there's a new
Thing going on new mini game to play
Oops, I didn't mean to press that
It's tomagotchi actually I actually really like playing with tomagotchi
If
Viewer takes care of sick tom role play easy peasy lemon squeezy
Where's the baby? Oh, it's it's evolving the baby evolved
What is oh no not this fucker again. Oh my god. It's an ugly fucking ladybug
Oh, why are you so ugly?
Wake up
Wake up I went to bed
No, it's it's a toddler in this phase. It's a toddler. I will let it live for now
Guys, I'll take care of she beholds a large rock
Like the the second like the first one I had it was actually like in hindsight
It was has been the first baby that I took the most care of
Was the cutest one. I will say that
Oh my god, Mari
How dare you there's only room for one deadly, but what oh I get a gun looks like an m4
Can I have it?
I like how the
Quest boxes just like totally cut off hammerlock. I can work one mission at a time. Okay. Thank you
So, I don't think I thought that's the story. You know, I'll do this optional mission
Is it does that mean I have to teleport all the way over there?
Thank you
I don't know where I'm fast traveling to
Am I what the hell
How the
What the hell how do I
I can walk it was behind the teleport how do I go back?
It's so I can't zoom in
It's sorted alphabetically
It's saying I'm already there
I have to walk back
Why it said I could fast travel
It said I unlocked two places that makes no sense
How does some dumb shiznit I'll tell you that much
Do I have stamina it seems not
I
What is this what is that is that like I don't know what that is
And there's kind of no fall damage from what I can tell
Please hold
It's so weird it's a respawn point I understood
Damn use those sound effects for a 3d edit
If you know you know why is it called Liarsburg that's like the shittiest name for a town
I don't get this I don't
What is whatever um over here
Get fucked
Yeah, why don't I use a shotgun for this
It's probably better to are you stuck
Oh
It's very hard to dodge it's like I don't strafe that fast. Ah
Monglet I'm gonna start calling you guys monglets
Oh
Maybe because the dot like the it's hard to strafe I give you a shield
Everybody's fucking dead
Because I killed them all
They were harlots now you're hard harlots. I mean what now you're monglets. Um
Oh my god, I feel fucking nauseous now. I don't even hey
You could end up living better just hit fire, okay
I
How do I
Oh where am I
Oh, that's where that is
Okay, I did it
Didn't I do it they're under me
Okay, I don't know how that makes a probably over here question mark
Hello
Oh
Hawk tour
Hawk tour if you don't hawk tour. I'm don't talk to her
Is there collateral fuck
Oh, jeez
Oh
I got a sneeze and I'm missing my shots for that reason. Ow
Okay
Oh
Hey, oh
What is that?
It's an incendiary weapon. What is this fucking destiny?
Oh
I'll hurt my arm
Destiny is borderlands
Oh that hurt really bad
Oh, I hurt my I couldn't
I fucked up my neck and then the nerve pain just traveled down to my shoulder down to my elbow that fucking hurt
I am falling apart
Uh, I'll probably
I'll do the side quests because they just seem good to have
Elevator
Elevator what do you do up to clap trap
We're gonna take him out steal my ship back and sail the sanctuary
Let's go this way my sanctuary. My sanctuary now with fears and lies
Angels take fly be careful taking down boo boo. He's one of those wait. I got stuff to do hold on brother
Okay, I got she I what ow, sorry to smack the mic. Where's the shielded favors one?
Sorry the way just cut him off was really funny
I
Played fun xp adds up quick understood. Oh my god, that's so far away
Okay
Thanks for chewing in my ear it's on an unexpected asmr
Out my tummy hort wait
Why did I press that? I used five dollars to look up what the fuck is that about?
How do I
Where's the map I need to get over there to use the elevator
Elevator
From what I got stuff to do bro. Do I have to go up there?
I do indeed
Oh my god, you're so tiny
You just a little what's the melee? Oh
How are you hitting me? Okay, let me just shock on it
Oh, you're so short I just aim above you
Oh
Can I have like a little bit more health?
Can I
Okay
Of course for melee the safe house power box stopped working I quit my new sorry hold on
I'm I have to do something before I speak to you
Well, there's this interesting skill tree. Um, actually let me what?
Is this an ak?
Holy crap, let's try it
Can I
I have a lot of fucking ammo for it
This reminds me of a hand cannon
Oh, I like the little animation I do when I put it away
Leave guns here. It'd be funny if there was a gun inside
Um, is there any health nearby help?
Oh
At least gravity is pretty forgiving here health
I don't know what that is health if you please help
Uh, I want to do health. I want to do health
Uh, excuse me. I want to help as you not to know what that is. Uh, I am looking for
What is it squad?
The health the syringe. How do I get up there?
I can open it up
Can I glitch it so I can open it?
Did I pick it up?
I just want to know how to get up there
I
Watch the barrels the barrels. What's about the barrels? What's about the barrels?
You really I am
French now
These barrels
Oh, I have a grenade. You know how a grenade press G to throw grenade
Uh, if I stand here
Do I get health?
No, this is not how this works
Is there a dude?
There is a dude
It said sacco
What is the I I
I'm assuming that is the elevator what I
Hold on
Are you kidding me? What is the health?
Oh
Kiske no
Coot oh corrosive barrel interesting
Can I open doors? No, I am too mentally enough to open a door. I am full
Look at my current objective, okay, I'm up there
Like I have to do something over there. Jeez the map looks a lot bigger than it actually is
Why is there so many?
What is up with that
He's called me a cunt
This is a cool gun
It's like an auto
It's like an auto acre which is very interesting
I was hoping that was an explosive barrel, but it's not hold on my eyes at you. I feel like
Hello
Is it okay overheat? I don't seem like it
At least the AI is bad
At least there's no like recoil control. I was like am I gonna have to is that like what is that?
Um, am I gonna have to like crouch like it's fucking CS?
Oh
You're gonna choke and stroke my lifeless body
Are you alive? Oh, okay. Oh give me the health. Thank you so much. I appreciate it. You really died for my sins. Um, can I not pick this up?
Slag barrel. That's what they call your mother
Excuse me
Oh that hurt me
Why do I sound like I'm fucking jorking it?
Actually, you know what you guys can third party each other. I'm just gonna hang out here
Well, that bully mong gets you
Because I have no health again
You're not ready for me
I'm not ready for you
Sorry, I'm looking at your messages in the chat everyone
Yeah, the maps look so much bigger than they are and I think I'm just so used to freaking Elden Ring that I'm like
Oh, this must be a long trek, but it's not
I
Well, oh ladder. Oh nice
Are you good?
Can I just
Can't believe this
Did he say that I can't believe this
What the hell is it me tweeting about I get notice for all the girls on my phone and I just see her say
I'm gonna stop walking by people's windows and looking in for something. What did she say?
I gotta stop looking through those windows while walking by I used to be fun
But I just made eye contact with
Can you recommend your favorite restaurants and your favorite food from there?
Hi, so I'm actually not a fan of vTubers. You're actually the first vTuber I've seen
I get that chat that tweet in or not tweet um that message in my chat all the time
Which is really funny to me
What I'm just
I
See just she never usually tweets in such quick succession
People actually do that I do that I'll walk by and look into someone's window
Oh
I match Emmys freak bro, I match her freak so well
Uh
Anybody gonna match my freak anybody gonna match my me
Oh, I feel like I have to sneeze again. I can't
I don't know what that is. I'm just picking everything up
Okay, someone said there is health below
There is a little plus sign that doesn't really make any sense to me
What's up with that
I
Hell oh
Um
Can I have that back?
Cheese it looks like it's gonna fucking hit me. Oh cheese
Yippie hey, I can open doors
Let's see
What shield do I have no kitty?
I have 289
I
Guess I'll just get the lead in shield
What is that
I
Boomie go away you don't need to eat any more ranch, dude
You stick
You're funny. I just wait. I just like I just say I leave it anywhere and I'll come and get it
Don't talk to me. Don't look at me. No contact
I can sell weapons
How do I
Uh, I'm assuming I click this sell. Okay, uh
I
Actually like look that I don't need the repeater or this one
Um
Booby stop, okay
You know what like I had this stuff over here because I didn't want to close it up yet because I was still munching on my fries
But I have to he's still licking the fucking ranch
I sold my equipped weapons. What does that do? I just sold my shield because I just got one
Can I equip it how do I equip it to a
I
That's great. Can I fucking equip it?
Okay, thank you
Ah
Nifty
Whole beans brother
What else do I need to do
Oh
More money
I don't really need that
Heavy repeater
I'll take that and I'll fucking sell it
I'm barely holding on. Oh, what's up here?
Huh
All right sick brother
This is wobbly wobbly wobble wobble wobble
Bye marie. Have a good night
Oh
Running running running we are running in a rich man's what what the fuck
That was weird
Is something just moved on its own
And me and boomi just got freaked out by it that was so weird. Why did it do that?
It's ghosts
Boomi it's okay handsome boy and I'd probably something just
Tension built over time you've caused it to spring up
Oh
Oh, I get a sting like a bee
Oh my they usually they literally use the word midget like
That's funny
Not politically correct anymore
Uh borderlands
Okay
Or they're saying dwarves
I did change it to the newer games. That's funny
Um, let me track
I'm not doing that. Oh wait, that's a story mission. This is an optional mission
This seems like it gives me a new shotgun in a rifle
So I'll do that
It's a hat of a gentleman and yet it's missing something some je ne sais quoi
I literally killed like 50 of them
Why are you walking away while you're talking to me?
All right, I gotta do it a couple times. I suppose
it's uh
Ammo dump. Okay. Well, I'm good on ammo
Wait
In a chronistic
Last day with a melee, okay, then I'll use then I'll use the rifle. What the how do I get out of here?
I'm stuck in here in this place
Help
Tell me I can't
I can jump up here
Come on
Sorry, I missed a little dumb
Last hit with a melee got it
Why are they so far away? I'll go do these ones over here first
Sick grenade jumps what do I like throw a grenade and
Oh, doesn't do anything throwing grenade. That was very I don't know what the accent is there. He doesn't sound like ng. That's for sure
Zenyatta tell him where he can stick his arrows in his quiver. No
I'm trying to stab it
I apologize if I wasn't clear enough. You see you need to kill the bully mong with a melee attack in order to harvest
It's fair. Sorry. I'm kind of maybe I shouldn't use the incinerate
Do I what am I supposed to do? Oh
Sorry, I was not reading
What the fuck am I in code leo go? What's this?
I have to kill it any to get back up very interesting. All right, it's fine genji's back. Um
Enjoy the new you that's cool
Again, I love it when games like incorporate
Normal gameplay stuff until like lore or make make it have a reason for it
It's I think it's very clever
Okay, I'm not gonna use this gun. I will be using
Uh this one then to get the
I need healing I require healing
I need healing
Be right back
Oh, I like how there's still shit here. That's so interesting. Huh interesting. Uh
Oh my god, you're so huge
Sorry, I'm just trying to get them knocked down. Oh my god, hold on
Uh
Can I you're literally gonna kill me hold on let me just back up a little bit. Why are you so fast?
Oh my god
They're like right on my ass
Oh
Fucking ammo. Oh see it didn't wait. There you go
I've just four times I don't know about that brother
Oh my god, you're close to death
Uh, I couldn't even grab the other one
I
Music's really good in this game
Oh my god
Stupid with it like make a mohawk out of it or something. That's cute
Food's with their fur. I can't see I can't really use the weapon
There you go. Is there any more
No
Okay, I have to go to a different spot. I wish you guys would drop health. That'd be great
Oh
Got around the whole fucking way back over here, what is I don't understand. What is this plus sign?
I feel like I should be able to do something with that
Health question mark no health question mark
No, but I could use some ammo so that's still helpful
This health vending machine is it up top is that what it oh, that's probably what it's saying
No, fuck I missed
I shot and then I missed I shot and then I missed
I see
Oh the lever's right there. I'm actually stupid at least I can use for an excuse that I'm just not feeling good
How many can I pick up
Can I fall down from there and get fall damage I'm kind of I'm kind of tempted to just what if I just
Little
Oh, are you serious fucking elevator then
I
What the fuck are these oh
Oh, those are annoying can I go in water
Water's cold
Ah
Can you all leave me alone? Thank you
Water's spicy it was a bit spicy. Oh my god, my
Those look like barnacles on the side of those things come on off. Oh, that's cool
That muscle looks so neat back in 2012 it still does to be on like this game holds up graphically because it's so stylized
If I have it if it's a monglet, can I do it? Oh perfect monglets are easier. That's for sure
No, I didn't mean to you know what I'm just gonna kill you
I'll kill the monglet
Monglets are easier to grab
Yes, I want the sniper rifle
Boots with the fur
Sell shading at the immortal graphics
Yeah, it does get so safe. Well, but then everybody
Like once like the stylized look right now is the fortnite style because everything looks like fortnite style
It's like that
it's like
It's almost
I'm trying to think of what to compare it to
It's like an update version
No, it's not I was gonna say it's an updated version of like
Team fortress, but I don't quite think so team fortress is still the characters are uniquely stylized in my opinion
Whereas all of the characters in fortnite look samey they all have same face syndrome
Thanks vault hunter. You've helped a foolish old man look far more badass than he deserves
I'm referring to myself
You look pretty badass. I'm happy I gave it to you. I'm not gonna lie
Welcome customer
Made key to safe in your travels
Good luck
Welcome to my humble shop
Pleasure doing business
My pleasure as always
Item of the day
All right, um, let's go back to the normal
I completed that
Oh, I'm good. I'm I don't think I want to do that one
I
Claptrap she's a mohawk fester game if you give it to him really oh
I kind of wish I gave it to claptrap for that
That's really funny, but I wanted the um, I wanted the sniper rifle since I already have a shotgun
I
Kind of want that hat can I get can I use some bully mong for to get my give myself a cool little like
Mohawk like over here. You guys can't see that. I'm gesturing with my mouse
um
So yeah, we'll keep it on that. So what do I got to do? I gotta
Go over there
Oh, hi rena
Are you know my cat just hopped on my desk
I'm so sorry rena. I cannot pet you right now though, especially because I have my allergies and you'll just
Use aspirate my allergies further. You're very cute though. You can sit on my lap. I just can't pet you as much
What this guy's
Oh rena you're falling down
I
Like your your moans are pretty hot
I won't lie pretty hot moans
Now does someone just have a fucking nade at me
I
Just get a little bit closer. Shall we where's the other guy?
Oh
Why does this do I feel like this isn't doing anything to you
Yeah
Piss for brains, yeah, that's pretty hard. I'll give you some more thoughts. Yeah
But stallion
What
What's the exclamation point is that cloud trap? Oh
Whatever happened to lane up here. Oh, it's an optional mission
I don't really care about a pistol right now. But thank you
But stallion's the best source
Clap trap is the same a voice actor
Used for clap trap in the movie rena's licking my hand while I'm trying to play this is great
No, you know what it should do whatever that is
Are you just gonna die? Okay
I like I like the uh using the environment
Hold on I'm trying to open this don't know what I just grabbed in there
I'm just wasting ammo because I thought it was an explosive arrow
Can I
Hello, can I not fucking climb am I mentally inept?
I
The killer rotters just take these I guess I'm just shooting over his head
Is a different voice actor they use jack black in the movie. What the hell?
Is everybody dead well, I'm gonna fucking loot shit then because I need ammo
I don't know what this is. What the fuck is that? What is this? Is this a site for this? What is
What the hell why did I just
Why did it switch the weapon? You know what I kind of like it. I'll keep it
This is kind of weird, but you know
Hold on hold on clap trap. I'm kind of
Oh
Sorry, I'm so distracted there's a lot going on
There's someone just shoot me I don't
Oh the fuck I have 60 health hold on I am just so overstimulated right now and I need health
I got Suisse bombed. I didn't even see
I didn't even know there was anybody still here. Can I please jump up? Thank you open? No
Oh
What that?
Shut up clock trap for a second. Okay. I'm definitely supposed to make this jump and I didn't because I thought there might be a ladder
Okay, let me try it again. Oh
Oh
Reena she's reena's sitting on my lap in a very funny way right now. All right ready
Yeah
There we go
treasure chest
Okay, white green blue purple orange
Oh two for one handgun
Nifty
Okay reena left she just left me
Sorry I fell down I need uppies
Okay
I need to go fucking back up don't I
Hold on clap trap hold on
I just needed oppies
I'm not ready
It's I thought you said poo poo
Boom and his brother boom
Ready to blow
Big bertha
Incoming badass. Why do you you're literally just I need health or I'm gonna die
I will not survive this
Precisely
Oh what the hell brother
Oh
There's nothing in here I can't kill anyone because I'm in a fucking boss battle
I
Crap I was almost an idiot
Listen, I deserve to be serviced. There's nothing wrong with that
Oh sick
Oh
Does it reset the mission? Oh, no, it doesn't very interesting
I
Can't die this good night. I can't get up. Please hold. Please hold
Oh
My god, I literally fucking hate the vaulting in this game. They're called vaults things for a reason and I can't even fucking get up
Hey
Uh, this doesn't seem like a good idea
Oh
And I need you
At least you turn around really slowly
Oh, you're still alive
High fire with fire
Oh, but you can give a fucking jump pack like you're fucking over that
Oh
I'm not getting critical
I wish I could slide I'm realizing how much I like sliding as a mechanic
I
Stop fucking jumping around Jesus Christ
Let's see how this works
I don't like having to scope
Uh, actually please hold I need to
A lot of guns
And there's maybe I can get close to you at the shoddy. I'm not strong enough to do that
Boom headshot
Shot
I've earned a skill point am I winning I don't have to shoot him
You're gonna shoot the whole cannon. Oh
I'm just I'm just here having a good time to sit in here happily
Sorry, hold on. I have to level my skills. Uh, you can just sit there and die one shot one kill
Excuse me
Half a graph. Oh, I can pull I can have mirage
I can be a decepticon
Press F to create a helmet and vanish for a few seconds as longer you're visible the more damage your next attack deals
But ending a visibility sooner results in a shorter deception
Okay, interesting
Oh, what the four did you come from? What the fuck?
I think I what am I throwing?
Oh
When it runs out
That's so interesting to me the fact the fact I can't pick this up there's
Interesting my inventory is now full
Well, I can get a rid a lot of these, uh, I prefer to sell them
I don't like this gun this target aim shot kind of sucks in my opinion
I think the one with the largest thing I'm a lover
Oh
The gun my personal gun makes it to the okay, it's torque guns that do that
Oh, I hate that I don't like it when you reload, but you actually like lose the bullets
If you didn't like if you didn't like fully empty the clip, um
Or the mag whatever
Okay
Badass token
Oh, um
We were mainly damaged to be honest
I will also do what
Okay
Oh
Let's do
Yeah sure
How do I change my uh
How do I change my outfit color?
How do I change me? Oh, that's cool
And move it around. That's actually really cool. That's a very intuitive
UI actually I very much like that
And if you'll look at it, I like that a lot actually
I have to find a station. Okay. Oh
Okay
Cool
Other guns that I should be
Holding
Should I hold this so I can sell it? Oh, yeah, this is 46. This one's 31
Cool
Hmm
What's up trap
Do any of them say fuck
This candle
Now
Can I shoot clap trap
Yes
When it's okay
The fact I can't shoot again. Okay, I was gonna say
Okay
This is fun psycho midget. Yeah, that's a that's a freeze
They're like because he did a good job in the boss battle now, we're just gonna give you a freebie
Anymore
It's pretty cute I like that
What do you got for me?
I
Can gun
I killed him wait, did I kill clap trap?
Did I legit kill crop trap
Did
No, did I
Because I'll actually be upset if I kill the clap trap. I will restart my game
He's gone for fuck off. Why would you say that? Why would you lie to me? Why would you lie to your madam?
Don't lie to me
Soaring dragon
Okay
Oh, wait, he's still alive. Thank god. Um, let me
Explose like a grenade when I load it. It's so funny
I'm not really familiar with the damage
rating
23 times 2 is this 13 times 13. So I'm a little
It's very interesting how these work. Let me just
I do less damage
I can't use this yet. Can I
Oh, yes, I can
Yeah, this is 13 pellets. Okay, interesting
Oh, okay understood
Yepy
Where the fuck are you?
Shut up, okay
Is this the checkpoint
Where do they
I'm gonna let that guy kill that
Because those things are actually really fucking annoying. What the hell
They sound like the dragons from game of thrones
These are hard those are hard to lead you literally have to spam it
Oh
Oh, that's cute
Oh any more
Give me your fucking why do you guys just have money hanging around?
Oh trash
You may look at guns that have slag I want to use them much for like high level endgame stuff
Okay, I understand you got yeeted. I blew him to the top of that ship. What the fuck
That's so funny
Where is the shooting
Oh
I can't really tell where
Where that I see that a muzzle flash, but like where is he?
Can you come over here?
I don't think I can wall bang you
Thank you. That's all I've always wanted
Oh, thank you
Are you still alive?
Oh
What that I don't know why my favorite part of games is just finding loot. I don't know why it's just very enjoyable for me
Magic you could like find loot like this when you just walk around
And actually let me back up
Okay, interesting I didn't know they do I grow
Oh
I'm just standing in the middle everything sniping is my favorite pastime
Sorry, I'm trying to help you and put you out of your misery, but you keep moving
There's another one, where are you?
There's another one I just saw you where'd you go?
Oh, I missed
I love sniping colors make your brain happy
How do you say my glasses?
Back
That's interesting
I like the the fucking um
Dial oh
I will take both of these. Thank you very much
I
Why am I let me just hit fire. Oh my god, it's hard to hit fire with this. Thank you
What the fuck why are there so many little guys?
It's also really weird
The dialogue is honestly very amusing in this game. I am enjoying myself. Ooh, can I eat this?
It's fish. I love fish. Oh, look how fucking goofy it looks
Let me um
Let me see. I want to switch to one of the other guns. Oh already
Oh, oh hold on
Can I double shield what is oh these are other things? Um, well, I'm just gonna drop this
Uh
Can I that's 78 can I switch this one and then can I drop that?
And then I can pick up this one and I'll save the other one
Uh, these are the shield lead and shield
I'm going to how much is this 33?
This is very crazy, Texas long rider
Fires as fast as you can pull the trigger interesting
Yeah, I like the the concept of like the different gun makers like I'm actually really very much enjoying this
Oh
I'm not saying there's anything wrong. I'm just like I'm wondering I'm wondering what the the plot reason for so many little guys is
um
This seems to be a mark for that just to find this accuracy
I'm going to call it the Texas long rider because that seems fucking crazy
I like the weapons. They're very cool. I love the design. I'm I'm actually really liking borderlands
I think I like it. I'm sorry. I think I'm enjoying it more than follow
Not although I like follow is it really fun, but because I just prefer skyrim. Um
This is a very interesting gun
This is insane
Very interesting gun
It's over here. Oh nifty. Can I buy this?
I can't buy right now
Fine, what the fuck
You know, I should back up because I actually I feel like I should be sniping these dudes
There we go
Is he still alive?
All right
Sniper is pretty powerful. Um, let's see
Can I pick this up? Oh my inventory is full
Okay, now we're getting to the point where I am
Getting more green weapons. So I'm starting not to care about anything. I do like the shotgun though. So I hold on to it
Sometimes I'll click enter in it or maybe because I'm clicking E
Damn it
I'm sorry 74
Yeah, if you die while sniping that's a good point
I have a skill point. Oh
I
Weapon swap speed
You massively increased damage
Oh, I like that although I don't really I'm more of a distant because I'm since I'm playing more of a sniper because he's an assassin
I'm gonna be more distant. So I'm gonna do weapon swap
um
I
And then I'll do
I don't know increase the fire rate
What what
Oh, what the hell I didn't even see these
I literally just saw this and this one and I thought I had to unlock these before I go to these
Okay, and I didn't even see this behind the fucking thing
Okay, have a good night. Bye
What time is it? Oh, that's almost all of it
Well, no, I know that for next time
Because then I would increase the critical hit damage
Although I do like the aim city is
Okay, yeah, I didn't see that behind there. I wasn't really looking over there
I still think it's still intuitive, but I'm just not paying attention
I
I kept thinking this guy was a fucking enemy, but he's just a poor guy poor soul
Got caught
in the the crossfire
Sorry, I'm a little sleepy. So my voice is a lot deeper
I feel like I should hipfire with this
Oh, you're already dead. I'm stuck
Um, maybe not
Can I crouch I can't crouch in this game
Her they're shooting from above me like right above me
I
I just um, I'm a little epee. Oh, hi
I'm gonna save my day
Need more sniper ammo
Oh, fuck me. Oh, what's this?
Hello, what the fuck are these?
What
Hold on I'm doing something
Just like give me a moment. I'm looking at cool shit. This reminds me of apex
That's nifty looking. Where's the other dude? What is he doing? I can't really hit him. He's in a weird spot
All right, we got this
This is a cool-looking pistol, which one's the best throw a nade? Oh, yeah
Ow
Okay, which one should you like?
I know this is 10 years before that you don't have to be fucking condescending dumbass
Um, I'm just saying the way it opens up just reminds me of that. Uh, which one is the best one?
Take them for value 43
I'll just grab the one with the most value
Where is
I hear this guy looks like he happened
What is what are they doing?
We can talk this through right here. They're beating him up on the ship. Is that the noises?
Oh
I know there's a way to probably go around but this is actually easier
I
He he he he
What the fuck is up with the vaulting in this game? I can't do it. Yeah
Okay, maybe I just go around maybe it's not as easy because I was hoping I wouldn't have to like deal with them
All right, let me just
I
Did you just get your health back? I don't
Something like that
Sell them at the medical oh good point. I forgot that I can sell them there. I keep thinking I have to sell them at um
Oh
At um her wait, where was it did I just run past it I did
What the fuck to where was it guys I mentally ill help
I could just
Oh wait, I never checked these
Okay
Oh
What I never opened this
Uh
I can't take them anymore claptrap. Why are you yelling?
Yeah, I kept thinking I had to sell them at like ammo places
Why do you sound like you're right next to me when you're not um
Oh, I can buy stuff back
How do I sell oh, okay
Well, uh, okay. Goodbye. I will miss you shoddy. We were so
Lovely to go there
I
Um, let me go grab those other ones
And that sounded kind of creepy
Oh, I thought I could run up that I cannot
Wait, how did I get over there? Oh, yeah, that's right. We
Very smart idea gentlemen, just grab it and go back and buy it
I mean sell it
The best damage one
It's portable clinic what can I get for you? I don't like the target aim shot so I will sell it. That's fine
I won't be defeated. What the fuck are you talking about dude?
Um, I kind of want to try out this gun so I won't sell it just yet
Gernade mods
Can you I'm gonna sell that and then there were
Which one
Almost did I can fix that
Instead of you look lonely. I can fix that. It's almost dead. I can fix that
um, so
So that one
See you real soon. I'm sure I'll equip that one
Um
That's a way to say that um
Oh, it shows me what I have equipped. Okay. I was worried already
I
You can mark them. Oh, that's smart. He's a little chuny
You can't vault in this game only and be able to three you can. Oh, okay gotcha
You can consume that voice thing in your is under what?
What's personal I don't even know where the personal thing is
You
The radio thing
In my
I don't see anything that looks like a radio because I'm blind
Oh, if I star it that that makes sense
You were right over it what?
What do you mean?
Radio
I'm so tired
Radio this
Madam in your backpack a last item this
Oh
Wait, what did I just do
What did I just do I just clicked on it
Excuse me. I ate it. What is that too?
And now it'll play when I unpause
Oh
That sounded highly sexual
Extremely chuny poor schmuck
I like to play with my toys clearly
All right, he only speaks in haiku's
Damn, he's very dumb impressive. He's just like me for real for real. Cut trap. What the fuck is wrong?
Ah
Where did you even go?
Oh, there you are. Hold on. Let me sleep. That's not it
Well, you please hold did he just say will you marry me?
Bring me a bucket and I'll show you a bucket
This game is very forgiving what the fuck
Oh
My god should have reloaded before I did this
Me thinking I can double jump like I'm in fucking destiny
I just sound like I'm fucking something. Why do I why do I talk like that? I clap trap
Is
Yes, you can
Are you serious you can definitely roll up these fucking stairs
Are you dancing? Oh my god, I love him. I truly do actually
Yeah
That's a toilet I was gonna try to snipe from the toilet
Nice don't know why somebody stuck that in there. Maybe they shout it out. You never know
Oh, yeah everybody just comes out
Oh, I missed that
Ow, what the fuck
Who's shooting me? Oh you you have like some sort of incendiary thing
Oh
Shot the barrel next to me I presume
I heard a little guy
No
Um
Where are the controls? It's actually a little bit hard again. I'm to piss off
It's hard for me to navigate things because again, I'm blind. So
There's a goon cave up ahead
He is baby no stairs
What am I doing, uh, because I see
Does that mean up?
I feel like that means up. What the fuck can I like?
No, okay, just waste bullets
This part is kind of yeah, because it says it need to ascend. Um, this is great because I don't know how to fucking get up there
How am I supposed to
Boys
Uh
Is an arrow on the wall
I see that arrow
Is that what it wants me to do? Do I run off and then jump up here?
Perhaps me thinks
Let's try it
Nope other wall
This one. Oh, I want to be different
I want to live life on the edge
Huh
Why did this actually work? Oh fuck
What
What oh there you are
Sorry, I need to line up my shots and take my time because I am just a small girl
I
Was pretty I want to try it again because I think I can go up that chain actually
Because it's definitely there for a reason
I missed that time
There's a shot
Oh
Anymore, okay
I just had a
I just had a dilulu moment when I swear. I thought I heard the whistle that you do
um
When you
Call torrent
Where is he? Oh again, I'm blind
More
Anymore I'm trying I'm trying to do stuff over here, man
Trying to trying to no come on
I know you can do that. I know you can do that
Okay
Yeah
Don't fall no damn it
I
Give up otherwise, I'll keep doing that for a long time. So I'm forcing myself not to
Actually, there's a lot of stuff that I killed people over here and they dropped who is panting so loud
Oh
Wait, can I do this and I sorry I'm trying to throw a knee. It's just not working
Can you do it again
I'm out of needs. Uh, are you in here? I don't know. I just picked up
All right, I guess I'll just
I should probably pay attention. Oh, what the hell user
Ah
Oh
I'm getting a bit cocky
Oh, I didn't know I my double click actually helped me there
I didn't know I could spam. Okay, what if I
Oh fascinating
Who's behind me? Where?
Oh
No, I gotta fight for my life to party. No, don't fucking walk away
Jesus
I don't particularly like that noise
I'm picking just a bunch of shit up
Oh, what am I doing? No, see I actually could have done that
I was I 100% could have made that and just like it would have been a shortcut
All right, leave the white clap drop
Oh sweet, I need a names
Thank y'all. Okay, that's what I have equipped. This is a pretty cool looking weapon
Damage
Oh
I always like the names of certain guns. I still wanted to try this weapon, but I don't think I'll have the time to
What business this is I never tried the critical crowd sourcing yet
I'll hold on to it
Oh, wait, I have a lot of money. What can I buy? Can I have some sniper bullets?
Am I not
Thank you
Oh
Boss battle time. No, I'm not a fan of those
I'm gonna start calling you guys my torture dolls captain flint bird baby bed
He looks like somebody from
What the fuck
I'm very much happy I got the sniper. Oh funny. You just set himself on fire
I'm a little confused why I'm only doing 20 damage. Oh fuck me
Oh jeez
These guys look fucking scary. What the hell?
Can I please
Oh
I
Don't have any health
Can't fucking I don't have any cover
Nice I love that for me
I can't really see
I'm hoping that there's a dude here that I can kill
I'm on fire. So like
The fp. Oh, yeah
Hey, you know, it's crazy. Do you see something in the top left corner?
I forgot about that skill
And
Um, okay, so it remembers I did all of that
Oh, I forgot that it still continues kind of where you left off, which is very forgiving this is explode
Okay, let me try other gun because I don't think this is cutting it anymore
It's how my god, she's yelling at me
What the fuck
I can't quite see it's actually better to do the fighting up here because then I'm safe with my little sniper rifle
This is actually it might be actually better to die
Although I don't know Flynn will come over here
Maybe
Boss won't spawn if I'm up there damn it. Well, are you sorry about that?
Are you sure about that
Oh
And I set fire
To the rain
Watched it burn as I touched her
Damn you're he's a tanky guy
Oh my god, I can't even fucking hit him
I can't die
Okay
Is he
Is he okay, I don't know if he knows he's literally on fire
Oh
How to ant well, you know, what's really convenient
Very convenient
Yeah, you think very sweet
What is this blue thing
I
Sorry buddy dad
It's nice for a skin
Didn't even need the skill, you know what boom
That's actually want to see how it works. Where's where's my duplicate?
Is there a cooldown for that? Oh, I see it. I see in the bottom corner
All right, now we just gotta get to my ship. All right
Which is the most expensive
All these convenient money I have I am rolling in cash
Actually, let me reload this and then I can pick that up
Are you mean I'm still full I can pick that up. Oh, it's a literal ship. I thought it was like a spaceship
This is fun. Hi
I like how he just dances excitedly. I just love claptrap
And now to set sail for sanctuary sorry rena's in the I like how I get $15 for that
Style points
Let me not fall off the edge
Oh
What where did he go?
Reina
Man that is not the litter that is the side
Number two
I
Like
Yeah
Sorry, I was very interested in what you had to say actually I'm gonna end it here
Let me find somebody to raid because I'm a little epee and I'm gonna go rest
Do I save is it just do I just quit?
Claptrap was going off Jesus Christ that was ridiculous. All right, let me just
Well, thanks for spending time with me today, I'll see you guys on monday, uh as I don't stream tomorrow
Um
So I hope you guys have a good day
night evening after moon after after moon afternoon or morning
Um, I'm gonna get some more rest. I'm probably gonna see if I can take another allergy pill fia is knocked out beside me
Reina is just
Standing and staring at me
Reina, what are you doing?
Why do you why do you look like that?
She's like peeking out from behind something and just staring at me intently. Um
I
Sorry, I kicked my freaking go XLR again. Hold on
I might need to I might need to plug it into the wall because that just keeps happening. I just kick it
Oh, all right, but
I hope you guys have
You know that you enjoyed today. I like spending time with you
um
It was really cool. Just
Thank you not for not making fun of my little snores
I'll just thank you for letting it just spending time with me and sleeping
See I do not recall
Is mercy streaming today?
Let me look at the stream schedule
She is it's a members only and I can't rate a members only. I think she's doing a little dinner party
um
I will
Bring
Well
All right
DK graves. She's doing the gta
I'll play
We'll hang out with her
Do some role playing
And I hope you guys have a good night. I'm sharing my screen. Oh
I forgot about that
No, whoops I forgot to pop it out. Um
Wait, I want to see what it looks like
Oh, don't look at the scripts. Don't look at the clips. Oh, no, I want to see what it says
It's literally stuff that you already know about
It's a how's it a schedule sneak peek when you've already seen it. It's for this week
V alert clip five. Yeah, that's being edited as we speak
Oh
Strawny sent it to me. She's like, what do you think?
Farts questions concerns. She never says thoughts. He says farts and it just cracks me up every time
um
I don't know why it says be alert clip when it's literally just me
Um, anyways have fun with DK
I
Always want to call it say DK don't kikong every time I see her name. Boomie. You must turned off my computer
He's put his paws on my computer and right there right near the button
Um, he is always farting on people. I would say fart raid, but don't say that
Uh, the last time uh, DK raided me. I was saying
something
No, I was making like a really like edgy joke that I felt so bad
Um, let me think let me think of a nice
What's a nice raid message y'all? It's a
Boomi boomi's like end it end it now cut the cameras
Um, yeah, it was a bit awkward. I did apologize profusely at her DMs
um
Because you know without context it sounds very bad
Don't it's not going to be jorking my peanuts
Oh
Less than three
Wabbit season she be I used to say she be raid. Um, and then she'll be like, oh gosh not her again
Um, you could just say she be raid. Oh my god. Hi boomi. Boomi just jumped up on my desk
Sir you can barely fit. Oh, it's because he smells the food
That's why it's because I moved the food and he can smell it and so he's trying to get to it. Haha
I moved it over here
Gotcha
um
She be very less. Thank you so much doki for that for that. Um
The don't know that was a very kind of view. He did not have to do that
Thank you guys for taking care of me today
Maybe next time we'll do a you take care of your sickly Dom
ASMR
I tickled boomi's face and now he's like shaking himself
Quick while he's distracted put it under the blanket
Haha, he doesn't know where the food went because he was wiping his face
Um
Thank you, I appreciate the get well soon
Thank you for pouting up with my sneezing and my sickness and me being sleepy and
I still wanted to just hang out with you on stream today. Um, I'll see you guys on monday
Uh
I need to make like a chain thread of you guys reminding me each day to water my mom's plants. Um
I like how you guys reminded me after I woke up and I'm like guys
I told you to remind me tomorrow morning. I'm like, it's not tomorrow morning yet. Um
But thank you
Hold on. Let me double check
Before I raid because I always raid people and something's going on
And something like they're about to end or something
Boomi's eating a fry that I accidentally left out
You guys are gonna see everything that I'm doing. Oh, you can see all everybody that I follow. Oh my god
Oh my goodness
Oh boomi, oh boomi just splashed me with water. He just stuck his paw in the water bowl
When did she start?
When did she start streaming and he just flicked the water at me
She started five hours ago. Holy shit. Okay. Well, I don't think she's stopping anytime soon. Um
Jesus
Well
I'm now more wet
I'm not even in the fun way, man. Um
All right, go hang out with with the car. Bye
Bye bye stinkies
Bye
As you are monday
And we have the member stream in the collab the collab
Oh
noises
um
And then the member stream is after like right after the collab. So be there
Or be square. I have to make my waiting rooms tomorrow. I should have done that today, but I was too to whatever
I also got to post my schedule and everything tomorrow
Yep
Can you hear him in the back? He's pushing something around. What are you doing?
Okay, bye